hello
everybody uh around the world listening
to this uh bolive
conference um I'm Dr Paul Billings the
chief medical officer of Life
Technologies and uh I have the privilege
of talking to you today about in
Innovative genomic analysis and some of
the challenges that confront this uh we
have uh about an hour to talk uh I I I I
hope there'll be lots of questions uh
you please submit your questions I'm
going to take the questions uh pretty
much at the end uh so that uh uh I'll
try to talk for 40 or 45 minutes and
then have uh 15 or so minutes uh to take
any questions that are available um and
I'm delighted once again to have the
opportunity to speak to you
all let's see about advancing this hold
on a second there we go um so the first
uh slide is a kind of an obligate slide
for me since I work for a public
corporation um I uh if there's anything
that sounds like investment device or
forward-looking statements uh in this uh
do not take it as any uh anything but my
own uh uh personal view of the world and
I certainly do not take it as uh as a
specific investment advice I am going to
be talking talking to you about uh our
instrumentation uh that some of the
instrumentation for which uh my company
Life Technologies produces uh we produce
uh except for a couple of things which
I'll identify research use only products
uh and research use only products are
supposed to be used in research not in
the in the uh Clinical Laboratory um and
uh I if I do talk to you about uh
Clinical Services uh for the most part
these services are uh governed by the
rules of Clea The Clinical Laboratory
Information Act and Improvement act and
uh are not FDA uh approved uh devices or
um
services so let me just briefly tell you
a little bit about Life
Technologies uh we're a over 20y old
company uh we have a very enviable
position worldwide as uh I think the
premier enabler of life science research
uh we are
cided in over
600,000 scientific Publications uh we
have been granted over 4,000 patents uh
and we have employees based worldwide
and have generated Revenue uh in excess
of 3.7 billion dollar in the previous
fiscal year so we're a big company um uh
we are in the process of uh uh being
merged with
thermofisher uh and if and when that
closes uh we will become an even a
bigger company with an even larger
worldwide
reach
um amongst the many many things that we
produce the many consumables and
platforms that Life Technologies produce
and we make about 50,000 uh items which
we sell in our uh uh both printed and
online cataloges um we make a range of
uh genetic and genomic analysis uh
platforms um and these can be used for
the whole range of uh important uh uh
analytic targets from the discovery
tools which would be uh for the uh for
the most part now our ion torrent line
the both the proton uh and the PGM uh
platforms uh to our con confirmatory
platforms and we have two uh uh FDA
approved platforms are uh Sanger
capillary Electro fesus uh equipment and
our
qpcr uh uh Quant studio uh platform uh
and then of course we make uh a variety
of of other uh
consumables uh uh Library prep
informatics other things that can be
used uh toh support uh genomic analysis
across the spectrum of its
activity so now let us let's turn with
that background and and my coming from
uh a company with um a manye history of
interest in both uh genetic and now uh
complex genomic analysis let's uh talk a
little bit about what genomic analysis
is and uh what can be done and and where
the challenges lie um genomic analysis
is not just uh measuring uh directly the
genes or the gene sequence uh it is a
conversion of lots of and of lots of
information uh into something that might
be usable uh in the clinical Consulting
Suite so uh family history information
is obviously important um some of the
conventional chemistries and biochemical
analyses which were often the
traditional way in which uh genetic
deficits were or or genetic anomalies
were identified are still important
cytogenetics whether one does it with uh
more conventional dyes or with molecular
probes remain uh particularly important
in uh in identifying movements of large
units of of Chromatin and and uh genetic
material obviously the
modification uh of DNA by
epigenomic U uh activity uh is uh
increasingly a source of analytic
interest uh as one tries to identify the
impacts of the genome and then uh
conventional
genotyping uh looking at directly for
mutations uh either uh directly or
through uh PCR based uh uh activities or
uh Gene sequencing which really is the
um synanon of genomic analysis because
it produces the uh sequence of the
genomic region uh that one might be
interested in analyzing all of these um
types of analysis some with more history
obviously uh we've been thinking about
family histories for over a hundred
years uh uh since the time of Darwin and
mendle really uh but we've also and
we've identified families for for
Millennia that had illnesses and but uh
all these other forms of analysis remain
uh an important part of complete uh
genomic analysis particularly as it
enters uh the clinical setting
now we're going to focus for the most
part recognizing this complexity on uh
sequencing analysis and uh of course uh
we've seen an enormous explosion uh over
the last 40 years or so uh in our
ability to uh uh sequence genes whether
they be uh in animal or bacterial models
uh or plants for that matter or in
humans and to
reliably reconstruct the sequence of
genes uh and the F most people talk
about uh about genetic sequencing as in
Generations the first generation was
driven by Fred Sanger and uh Alan Maxum
and his colleagues at Harvard um and uh
the Sanger sequencing uh Remains the
gold standard of uh uh of sequencing uh
maximum Gilbert sequencing is still done
uh in many places as well and of course
Fred Sanger and Ry Gilbert uh have
received their Nobel prizes in part for
their work on uh sequencing uh which was
so important in uh setting the stage uh
for the Human Genome Project and for
many of the important discoveries uh
that have been made over the last few
decades then uh around the time of the
generation of the um uh of the Human
Genome Project it became clear uh that
we needed to uh
enhance uh our throughput for uh of
sequencing in order to uh and we didn't
even really know how big the human
genome was at the time but uh as we now
know the hpid genome is about fre
billion bases uh in order to do three
billion bases on a Sanger platform would
have taken many decades and so uh uh new
techniques often called Next Generation
uh techniques techniques were developed
um there were several uh there remain
several that are in uh commercial and
clinical application now uh but these
allowed for uh rapid sequencing of small
segments and uh using uh informatic
tools uh the Reconstruction accurate
reconstruction of uh of large uh swats
of sequences and uh Next Generation
sequenc and really drove uh the
completion of the Human Genome Project
uh during uh the second half of the 90s
um we now have uh at this time in uh
2013 a whole series of newer uh
Technologies might be called uh next
next Generation sequencing or third
generation sequencing uh and they
involve uh both uh light uh technologies
that involveed light and all the the the
second generation or next Generation
sequencing are mostly light uh driven
Technologies or uh those that use
electronic uh currents or other or other
methodologies uh to detect the
incorporation of DNA bases by
polymerases uh and uh these electronic
methods uh of which uh I'm familiar
primarily with one the ion torrent
methodology um is um uh has some very
significant advantages uh those
advantages uh I hope will become clear
uh in the further slides but the point
is is uh that I wanted to make by this
slide is to say that there has been uh
already three and and depending on how
you divided there may be four
generations of sequencing technology
available uh and that this Innovation uh
has been astounding uh in its uh ability
to uh increase the output of uh of
sequence available for analysis by uh
researchers and
clinicians this slide gives you a sense
of the pace of this uh of this
Innovation uh and uh uh so let's just
say that um uh beginning uh in the
around the 1960s uh there has been an
incredible uh increase in the output of
of uh of human genome sequence uh and
sequencing in general uh and uh that
this output uh seems uh absolutely uh
uneed uh I do not think we're uh we'
have seen uh the top of the curve uh and
so both in terms of speed uh to
completed sequence uh and amount of
completed sequence in that period of
time uh we've seen really unimaginable
uh Improvement in the uh in
sequencing uh one other sort of measure
of this uh is uh in one of the
electronic forms of uh of sequencing as
the uh the iron torrent method which
simply measures uh the change in PH uh
as polymerase moves along a uh a genomic
sequence and incorporates the
appropriate bases it uses natural uh
bases there's no uh modification of
bases it simply allows these reactions
to go on in micro tubes micro plate uh
kind of format that these
um represent but the the reason that I
included this slide is just to show you
that over the course of uh you know
roughly two years uh every six months
there has been a log increase in the
output uh of these chips uh and uh uh we
are now uh at outputs in uh that uh
allow for a whole genome sequencing uh
either on a single chip or even multiple
gen genomes depending on the coverage
the amount of repetitions that you want
in any particular site on a particular
chip and it certainly allows uh for the
exome the express genome uh to be easily
sequenced on one of these chips and the
time uh for that sequencing uh for the
sequencing part uh irrespective of the
analytic part or the uh the front end
where one uh has to prepare the samples
but the actual time on the machine uh is
measured in hours uh when uh back in the
days of uh where Sanger sequencing was
was the dominant um uh form of
sequencing you would talk about
sequencing times in days and weeks uh
now we're talking about minutes and
hours for a very large outputs so um
it's really quite remarkable uh this
really rapid Evolution uh in uh Power
quality and output of uh
sequencing now what this of course has
allowed uh this remarkable Innovative
burst in the genomic sequencing uh Arena
uh is a very profound draw up in the
cost for generating uh a genome or a set
of bases a very high quality um sequence
uh and so as you can see this um uh
sequencing um activity uh has exceeded
uh in terms of cost and productivity uh
the output of the um semiconductor
industry that was dominated by Mo's law
uh and so genomic sequencing uh is
progressing uh much faster than Moors
law now of course our challenge is not
only uh to drop the cost uh of uh
generating uh human genome sequencing
but also to uh increasingly demonstrate
that this uh increasingly inexp
expensive activity uh has value and then
of course the value of the information
not just the low cost of the data the
value of the information in my view is
increasingly important uh and so that
tension between a lowering cost which
makes it uh hopefully broadly available
and increasing value of the information
uh which might uh increase which might
uh you know dictate its uh its overall
value in the clinical setting and uh be
important in reimbursement discussions
um this is an interesting tension which
is being played out uh in the genomic
analysis world but um I think the
message has to be clear this is an
enormously productive segment of uh of
human biology uh which is uh uh where
Innovation is producing remarkable
remarkable
results um and not surprisingly uh if
one looks at uh Next Generation and
third generation placements of machines
around the world uh we are seeing
increasingly that these machines uh as
they become more and more affordable as
they become uh move from requiring large
rooms with ventilation and uh and many
technicians to uh desktop models which
are almost uh autonomous in their
operation uh that we have the
opportunity uh to um uh deliver
sequencing worldwide and that uh this
increasing productivity is reflected by
increasing placement increasing interest
and increasing
use so now let me turn uh to an example
really uh so yeah I I've just made the
argument that um uh human genome
sequencing uh has gone through in the
last couple of decades a remarkable
technological transform uh which um
makes the generation of the data easy or
easier uh but why bother and uh I I I
there are many examples of why bother
I'm just going to give you a couple um
the first is uh a study that I was uh
pleased to participate uh in uh with my
colleagues at the the tgen uh The
transational genomics Institute in uh
Phoenix Arizona and also colleagues at
us oncology uh a large network of
oncologists that practices here in uh in
the United States uh and we began to
look at a series of women um who had a
so-called triple negative breast cancer
uh breast cancer is a lovely story uh in
the sense that many many women uh who
have breast cancer uh have undergone
molecular uh testing and uh they either
have uh a herto uh amplification or have
uh susceptible uh alals at their
progesterone receptor or estrogen
receptor sites and so are able to uh um
um uh have specific targeted therapy
directed at their cancers which has
improved the outcome of people with uh
ER positive PR positive or her two
positive uh breast cancer uh enormously
um and um the FDA has approved both uh
these test and the um and the drugs
associated with treating these but there
are a lot of women including many women
the African-American Community uh who
have so-called triple negative breast
cancer do not have any of those three
markers and uh in general their uh
cancers are more aggressive and the
outcomes of women with triple NE breast
cancer are poor um so we put together a
series of uh 14 cases of women with
triple negative breast cancer uh and I'm
going to just show you uh what the power
of some of this uh kind of analysis can
be uh these women uh uh we had tissue
from their uh their tumors uh as well as
uh normal uh breast and blood uh we uh
sequenced uh their genomes uh their
transcriptomes all their transcribe GS
uh findings were confirmed uh by
orthogonal testing by an outside side
testing agency and I'm just going to
show you an example of uh one of the the
cases and what might uh occur so this
was a 60-year-old European woman uh who
had um had been given a chemotherapy but
had a recurrence uh this is a picture uh
a kind of a u
dimatic um um representation of her
genome
sequenced if you look uh carefully uh at
her somatic tissue at her tumor tissue
and compared it uh with um uh with her
normal genome around uh in her blood and
in her surrounding tissue uh we could
identify uh several genes which were
over and
underexpressed uh in her genome um uh
and uh appeared to have uh susceptible
mutations uh and that were of interest
uh to The Experts were looking at this
uh at this genomic
sequence uh and uh looking more
carefully at the pathways that were
involved uh we could see that uh uh her
mutations uh potentially uh were uh
involved
in a couple of fairly well described
Pathways and um The Physicians who were
caring for her and who were part of this
uh clinical study uh were aware that
that some of these Pathways were
involved in cell survival other of these
pathways are involved in cell
proliferation that mutations in this
area uh could alter the uh the cell
cycle characteristics in a uh in a
tumorogenic or oncogenic way and they
also was were aware that there were uh
drugs that were in um early development
which specifically targeted uh these uh
these
Pathways so um we um uh searched uh
available databases and found a uh Phase
1 clinical trial uh that appeared to be
uh uh interested in targeting uh the
pathways that might be mutated in this
triple negative breast cancer patient we
enrolled uh this patient in that uh
those phase one clinical trials uh and
this is just an example uh that that
after a couple of uh cycles of uh of
targeted therapy directed at the
mutations that had been discovered in
her triple negative breast cancer
analysis that she'd had a rather
profound significant reduction in her
tumor load uh after her
reoccurrence um and so this is that's
just an example of one way in which
NextGen sequencing uh can impact uh the
lives of uh individuals and of course
can uh uh uh Target people uh for uh
clinical trials and hopefully those
clinical trials uh can help them do well
a second area where uh nextg sequencing
is already having a very profound effect
uh is in uh genetic disease um we're
seeing a lot of activity across the
Spectrum um from uh prenatal settings
and even preconceptual settings uh
through adulthood um there have been
many Technologies which have applied
individually uh in these areas uh all of
them are now converging on nextg
sequencing um one particularly important
area is in a rare and idiopathic uh
apparently single Gene disorders whether
they're in uh primarily in pediatric
settings or in adults uh and here are a
couple of examples of uh of cases in
which uh individuals or uh siblings have
been affected uh uh by um these complex
uh but single Gene disorders and uh
sequencing uh has allowed for the rapid
identification of those genes uh and
allows for uh us to accumulate more
knowledge about uh how these genes
impact the human phenotype but also may
suggest important care Pathways uh in
addition uh and we're seeing again
worldwide application of this use of
nextg sequencing uh because of the
sensitivity and iterative nature of uh
NextGen sequencers uh uh if you target
uh sequences on specific chromosomes uh
it allows for very sensitive uh U
counting of those chromosomes and if
those chromosome material happen to be
in the plasma or blood of of a pregnant
woman uh some of those will represent uh
the chromosome material of the fetus
that that uh woman may be carrying and
so it can be used in prenatal diagnostic
settings and so we are seeing uh a
proliferation maybe even explosion of
non-invasive prenatal diagnostic testing
uh using uh sequencing platforms uh to
count uh chromosomes primarily uh sex
chromosomes and uh chromosome 21 which
is associated with triome the triom 21
syndrome but as as you can see from this
uh set of data it also can be used to do
uh uh chromosome 18 and 13 uh which are
also uh uh sometimes involved uh in uh
uh abnormal uh fetus uh conceptions so
um um both in the prenatal setting uh in
uh pediatric and adult genetic diagnosis
and cancer settings we're seeing an
important application of uh these
genomic analysis
methods now what are the challenges
well uh first and foremost
um there are a number of issues uh that
come just after uh you run your genetic
material through the uh next gen
sequencer uh you need to uh realign uh
this information uh you need to call out
whether uh the information is accurate
and you've detected a variant from a uh
from a normal or uh uh or or you do not
have a variant from normal and then you
have to decide whether that variant has
any clinical information or not so there
are many levels of uh the bioinformatics
pipeline which need to be uh carefully
analyzed carefully reviewed and
carefully controlled uh and this adds uh
this is enormous challenge we uh in many
ways and I'll emphasize these in a
minute have not reached those uh those
answers
yet um and there are many others uh I've
I've listed them here in uh in a set of
uh of uh of bullets uh I'm not going to
read each one of them for you but let me
just say that whether you're considering
the economics of of developing new
technologies or validating them or
getting regulatory approval whether um
how you deliver that information solving
some of these informatic problems uh
storing uh the huge amount of uh of data
uh whether it be in raw sequence uh in
variant files or in simply in the
medical record uh provides a series of
challenges and um uh uh of course
setting standards of what is quality
sequencing uh what kinds of
confirmations are required uh in order
to act on sequencing data uh since uh if
you're doing for instance whole genome
you have three billion targets how many
errors are you going to allow if you
sequence all three billion bases uh in a
uh uh to in a clinical setting for
instance that's an unknown uh and so um
uh there are a variety of challenges
which need to be addressed uh as uh this
technology makes its way uh into more uh
clinical settings uh and in settings
where desperate and sometimes very ill
patients are using that
knowledge um
so what are uh uh let me expand on just
a couple of these um uh areas where we
need um U more information or we Face
challenges uh one is of course we need
more data about uh Normal and abnormal
genetic variation in the population and
uh in some cases when we're talking
about rare melum disorders we don't need
a whole lot uh because if we just have a
few people with a the same disease and
they have uh this mutation in a one or
two genes we're we're pretty safe and
knowing that that's what's what
where the money is uh but uh when we get
to other less rare disorders and
certainly as we get to Common disorders
we need broad-based public participation
to know what kinds of alals are
associated with disease and what kinds
of dis are alals are associated with
normal variation some of these alals
will vary uh having to do with their
origin and the regions in which we're
doing this work and so we really need
Global participation in uh clinical
genomic uh research uh in general
participation rates have been
small uh uh happily we have some
repositories that have been developed
over many many years which can help with
issues like this but uh the problem
Still Remains that the participation
rates are low and some of these
repositories haven't uh uh been properly
consented so they can't be used for
further population data so um uh we have
some challenges uh around the generation
of standard population data and other
kinds of population
Norms uh a second area of challenge uh
is around the question of just storing
this data this this slide is included
just to give one a sense of the size of
um an amount of storage uh that one
would have to uh to uh create uh to
really uh start to do global
a high participation rate whole genome
sequencing on individuals now uh um
happily uh we don't have to do whole
genome on everyone uh right away uh it's
an interesting important for
standardization important for research
of course uh but uh we can start with
more targeted panels with the ex uh the
exome uh and uh work out from there and
so um uh we can we have some time uh to
deal with the big impact of this problem
and uh I'm encouraged that innovation in
uh in storage and in in in and dropping
in the cost of storing uh the this
electronic information uh is occurring
uh but it is a challenge uh and it will
be an impediment uh to the proper an
analysis of uh large genomic data sets
if we don't uh see innovation in data
storage uh and then and a reduction in
the cost of data
storage uh another area of challenge is
as I've stated before the need for
standards um there are a whole bunch of
areas in which we need uh better
standards uh simply what is a
highquality uh genomic sequence what
defines it what controls uh need to be
available one uh defines for genomic
analysis clinical utility and what are
the data requirements for showing
clinical utility um how do you uh
properly compare uh and uh competing uh
Technologies or even synergistic or or
contingent Technologies uh when you are
a Health Care system or a payer um and
then all sorts of other uh areas where
standardization might be whether it be
in research consense and trial design or
or in many of the other aspects of
Health economic data Gathering which
often goes into the um into the uh
decision making uh of healthc Care
Systems or Healthcare payers or
countries for that matter whether
they're going to adopt a uh a test or a
a set of data so all these areas are
complex areas uh where we need uh better
standardization in the absence of
standardization we're going to be
wasting uh lots of time and money uh
which could be uh that are spent on
Direct patient care and
research um there are obviously uh in
health care in general uh and in genomic
medicine and in in the proliferation of
genomic analysis very significant
economic challenges as well our our
sense of right and of equity would say
that we should uh deliver the benefits
of uh Equity anal of genomic analysis at
a very low cost which would allow it to
be a Universal solution in healthare uh
but we also recognize that uh R&D is a
costly activity uh we're seeing that uh
as our research budgets are decreasing
uh uh in the United States and in uh
other developed part of the world and uh
that we need a return on investment in
order to pursue some of these commercial
opportunities uh we've already talked
about uh the importance of demonstrating
uh clinical utility and that's uh an
important integral part of the economic
challenge um we um to distribute and
support properly this complex
information and to provide the
electronic uh databases and Records
required is uh timec consuming expensive
um in general uh the healthc care
environment the the rising cost of
Health Care uh puts a puts a sort of a
cold uh uh it's like a cold shower for
those of us who are trying to innovate
and bring uh new new kinds of
information into the healthc care
setting uh primarily because uh you know
uh Innovation is viewed as expensive
even if that Innovation is targeted at
improving efficiency of the Health Care
system and thus eliminating waste or
actual cost cutting um uh in Innovation
is viewed often skeptically and then uh
in uh in the United States in particular
uh uncertainty about uh how one submits
a bill and what what might be paid if
one does submit a bill properly this all
becomes uh an important part of the
economic
challenge so uh let me conclude uh now
and and then uh take some questions I
hope there will be some questions um but
um let me just say that
um Innovation and genomic analysis uh is
progressing and its translation and it's
application is breathtaking in its uh uh
in its speed and its power and it's
progressing rapidly uh while uh the
genes and the genome are not the answer
to every uh disease and disorder uh uh
it is uh important to understand uh the
genomic contribution uh to all forms of
illness uh in some cases it may have a
significant contribution in other cases
it may only have a supportive or minor
contribution that but to have it be
allowed it to be analyzed to allow uh
the analysis of uh of the interaction of
of genomic elements within the genome
so-called modifier genes which may
increase or decrease the pathological
nature of a of a pathological variant
these are all enormous progress in our
um in our system and uh um I think we
should be very grateful that such uh
progress has been enabled uh by the
Innovations of uh of the technologists
who have worked so diligently to give us
the human genome sequence and all the
developments thereafter uh in cancer in
idiopathic diseases or unknown diseases
and certainly in prenatal Diagnostics
genomic analysis is already uh being
used in the clinical setting uh
thousands of individuals have benefited
from Next Generation genomic analysis um
uh and this uh is only going to increase
uh I do think that uh a standardization
and uh and uh regulatory Clarity uh will
help Foster this translation and uh and
obviously uh reimbursement is a key
element to delivering a return on
investment for those entities that are
trying to drive uh this genomic
information into uh useful clinical
information in the uh clinical setting
there are many challenges uh to this
otherwise really Dynamic and important
story
um we want to solve those challenges
because uh remarkable Innovation needs
to continue we have many many unmet
needs uh in the Health Care System we
have many patients who are suffering uh
unnecessarily who could uh benefit from
uh genomic analysis and targeted
therapies uh we have many disorders
where we don't even have the beginnings
of a therapeutic approach uh and we have
many people who are
misdiagnosed now all these things can be
uh improved in that uh in that
situation um revealing uh data becomes
available is used properly and benefits
all and is properly valued so it it's
very important that we uh make our data
available broadly uh that people
understand that that
information uh while the the cost of
developing the data may be decreasing uh
that the information to make that data
highly valuable and into useful
information can be uh extremely
expensive and time consuming and that we
need to put uh proper value on that and
that the full application of uh next
gener and whole genome sequencing uh
will become universally available in the
future uh if current trends uh continue
and CH and the challenges that I have
outlined and others are addressed and
that that of course would be uh a
wonderful Legacy uh of the Human Genome
Project uh and all those individuals who
have spent uh greater part of their
careers uh working on the challenges of
translating genomic analysis uh into do
uh common practice in um in human health
and uh and medical care and with that
I'll say thank you uh and uh I I see my
light flashing so I believe there are
some questions uh we have about uh looks
to me like we have about 20 minutes uh
in order to discuss any questions that
might be available and I will now uh see
what I can do about uh finding those
questions all right and there are a
couple let's see if I can get to
them um so the first question that I
have let me see if I can um so there's
this one
um what in your
opinion is the primary limitation behind
low participation in genomic sequencing
is it the cost or lack of full
understanding of the utility lack of
obvious profit potential ethics Etc well
that that's a wonderful question um and
um it probably depends and it's that was
offered uh by a colleague at the
University of Alberta and I very much
appreciate that question um in my in in
um in my
opinion um the um it varies a little
from setting to setting first of all I
don't think that we uh have ever had a
public campaign certainly not in the
United States uh and and I I would doubt
in um many other country uh except for
the high participation rates that you
see in some smaller countries like
Iceland and some of the Scandinavian
count countries but uh we need a public
campaign that says that research
participation is a public good that it
is beneficial to your family to your
neighbors and to your community to
participate in research I mean there's
some parts of genomic analysis that
simply cannot occur unless we get
broad-based public participation in
research and you know rather than uh
have it be a you know a legislative or
uh you know public policy process that
gets you know enforced by law and we
have you know a car or a stick that gets
I I would like to see uh an attempt made
to
educate broadly amongst the public about
the value of research
participation I I think uh in addition
that fear of uh the of of violations of
privacy or of so-called genetic
discrimination uh that might arise from
the misuse of uh otherwise uh uh you
know ethically uh captured and and
beneficial research participation I I
think the fear of this and the and maybe
some actual instances in which uh
coercive practices have occurred uh make
people concerned that uh uh
participation in research and genetic
research uh is not safe um I I think the
lists are small uh but I I I've always
been in favor of enhancing uh the legal
protections uh against misuse of genetic
information I think uh your genetic
information uh should not preclude you
from getting uh health care or other
social benefits shouldn't uh should not
be preclude you from getting jobs jobs
or promotions that you you otherwise
qualified for and uh I uh uh I would
like to see us uh continue to be
vigilant uh that um uh knowledge of our
genome uh and of our what's the contents
of our genome uh does not uh um get uh
substituted for uh knowledge of uh the
content of our character and our ability
uh which are of course the major
determinants of our success
uh in in our lives and um I
um uh you know I have worked uh over my
career to try to make sure that people
understand uh the differences between
those um those are the I think those are
the two major reasons why we haven't
seen better research participation um um
so education and fear if you like uh and
both of those are addressable I think uh
and um should be uh um on the uh on the
docket of our politicians and our
leaders as well as our scientific
Community as
well we have another
question and that question is while much
was discussed about economic limitations
any examples of positive economics
impacts of genomics that have been that
have been clearly
demonstrated after all the the type of
information would be crucial to increase
chances of of funding increased
participation in further genomic
um sequencing and studies so um what
we're asking for is um uh is specific
examples where um uh the development of
genomic sequencing information has in
and of itself uh allowed for uh clear
economic impacts um and the answer is
there are several Frank
um uh and I'll just touch on a on a
couple um the um the analysis of breast
cancer uh either uh by uh the provision
of the her two test uh or uh in some
cases in women with low grade uh breast
cancers uh with the provision of tests
which allow one to avoid chemotherapy uh
by um by uh um looking at the uh
expression of a set of genes uh in those
breast cancers and uh deciding that that
breast cancer would not benefit from
chemotherapy uh there have been clear
economic studies uh in those settings
and uh it is very clear uh that um they
have very significant the elimination of
unnecessary chemotherapy uh in uh early
stage breast cancer the elimination of
unnecessary chemotherapy
uh in early stage uh prostate cancer um
um are targets where molecular analysis
has already clearly demonstrated a
positive economic benefit in addition um
in those uh situations and they may
represent 20 or 30% only at this point
uh of the applicable cases but uh in
those uh unknown disorders primarily of
childhood
sometimes they're syndromic uh sometimes
they're more focused uh where U either
whole exom or whole genome analysis uh
has provided a a clear Target a clear
diagnostic uh Target and answer uh for
those uh individuals uh that focusing of
uh activity uh that focusing of the
diagnosis the the uh so-called
resolution of the medical Odyssey that
some of those patients are on uh
foretells significant economic
saving because in the absence of a a
concrete diagnosis uh many of those
individuals continue to have uh utiliz
lots of health care lots of Imaging uh
lots of specialized testing uh which
once they have a a clear diagnosis they
uh do not require and so um in the area
of the medical Odyssey the unknown or in
your past
uh genetic disorder um we um we have
good examples of the benefit of uh on a
health economic terms of genomic
analysis I think those are the two uh
primary ones um obviously as
non-invasive prenatal testing uh using
Next Generation sequencing uh comes on
board while next you know it's not a
whole genome type of analysis it is
using uh sequencing uh uh technology to
uh change uh from U an invasive test an
amniocentesis test uh to a and a variety
of other tests whether they be fetal
ultrasound and and biochemical analysis
of the fetus contribution in the
mother's blood um to a a Next Generation
sequencing uh I believe we're going to
see overall positive economic impact of
that uh technology as well um and um all
those are important uh Health economic
benefits so there are several uh that I
can point to that are already available
but I I think we need um better testing
uh and Better Health economic studies um
I actually am in the process of writing
a paper uh right now uh in which uh we
we looked at the clinical utility of a
um a lung cancer uh risk
stratification uh at early stage lung
cancer risk stratification test and
we've showed uh very significant
improvements in uh clinical utility um
but uh we need better uh uh outputs
better ways of capturing the cost of
improving that CL uh the of improving uh
that clinical utility uh what are the
cost
implications um it's easy to to to
assess the cost of the test it's also
not so hard to assess the cost of the
chemotherapy for instance but what are
the what are the costs and benefits and
efficiencies around um faster diagnosis
better prognosis we've never had a
system that could do that before and we
need better economic signals better
economic data to do that so I hope that
answers that question there is another
one um um from a colleague uh I believe
in uh Saudi
Arabia um what is practic practicably
the application of innovative analysis
to routine analysis for end users and
also it needs a large community to be
trained and second issue is the cost in
economics um let me just see if I can
understand this question uh what is the
practicability of application of
innovative analysis to routine analys
for end users well so I I think what
you're asking asking is um why should
genomic analysis
replace what we have now the routine
analysis uh and uh is for instance the
training of uh physicians in the
community a barrier to this and then uh
is economics a barrier to this too well
I I think the only reason we should uh
replace a uh an old technology with a
newer one is because uh if the newer one
one provides more accurate uh
information or if it's only as accurate
as the old way if it provides it in a
new uh format or in a new or faster
allowing for efficiencies or reduction
of waste in the system otherwise I I'm
perfectly happy to stay with the ways
that I was trained and the tests and
information that I was used when I was
in a younger doctor in training but uh
the point is that uh genome IC analysis
uh in many ways is more sensitive uh in
many ways is more definitive uh and uh
allows for um more uh sensitive and
specific information about the genetic
component uh of a in a particular Health
Care setting and so uh while um in some
cases that is not currently useful uh
and those should then thus uh require
more research to decide whether they
should be applied uh genomic analysis
should be applied but in many cases
particularly as I said in cancers uh in
um in idiopathic or unknown disorders in
kids and adults and uh and in uh and
prenatal diagnostic settings uh I think
uh genomic analysis is going to become
uh very much uh the standard and replace
older methods uh will there be uh will
it require uh new training and education
for uh heal Healthcare Providers
absolutely uh this data is in many ways
foreign and esoteric uh to uh uh even
recently trained providers and uh so it
will require very skillful uh
communication uh to make those uh uh
tests and the their results useful in
the clinical setting uh it has um um it
has fostered the whole area of genomic
Physicians and genomic healthc care
providers of which I am one um but there
are also U new types of Pathologists who
interpret uh the information as it comes
off the machine uh so uh we're seeing
new specialization in the medical
community to support uh primary
physicians and um and in addition as I
said um while the cost of the um uh of
the data coming off the machines is
dropping uh the value of its information
and uh all the other uh things that need
to require to cause the system to use
this information in the most appropriate
way um is
um still uh to be determined but is
certainly more expensive uh than simply
the generation of the data off the
machines and so um we're trying to uh
reach a uh practical equilibrium which
will depend a little bit on the setting
in which the information is delivered
whether it be uh the developed world or
the developing World whether it be an
academic Medical Center or in a
Community Medical Center or somebody's
uh Consulting Suite uh and so all these
things will impact uh what what the cost
of this is to the end user and uh how
it'll be
used uh I think that uh uh is the end of
the questions that I see uh asked uh
wait no no no I think there may be
others uh let's see uh there
is uh I have a comment that says thank
you for wonderful answers uh thank you
yourself uh that's my colleague in
Alberta thank you very much there's
another question let me uh see what that
one is
um if there is a mistake this again
comes from my Saudi Arabian colleague uh
if there's a mistake in genomic analysis
how do you counter check that whether we
can uh as uh we can repeat other
analysisis easily okay so that's very
good question so how do we
confirm um you know we're either whether
we do a large panel uh whether we and
get a variant that we've not seen before
um or we do an exome or a whole genome
analysis uh how do we confirm that uh a
finding uh is not a false positive
finding um and um uh and then um and and
something that we should take action on
well there are many levels of
confirmation first uh Next Generation
sequencing methods allow for multiple
multiple measurements of the LOI of
interest in other words when you do a a
germline analysis of a a piece of DNA
or or analysis of a sematic isssue like
a cancer uh you are you're measuring
these bases multiple times and so
obviously if uh you get some variability
in in in those multiple measurements
that would clue you to the fact that
there might be an error so the the
iterative nature of Next Generation
sequencing is in itself a
control um the second thing I would say
is that that may very well be true but
um uh certain regions of the genome are
more difficult to sequence than others
for biochemical and physical reasons
irrespective of the method of sequencing
that you're uh uh uh trying to to apply
to it and different methods whether you
use the uh light methods uh or you're
using electronic methods or other kinds
of methods to to um um to do this
analysis have different biases and are
are more prone to have difficulty
sequencing certain kinds of uh of
sequence uh formations within the genome
so uh knowing that you can uh use some
informatic tools to uh correct and
improve and reduce the number number of
mistakes but with all that being present
you're still at the end of the day going
to be delivered a set of of sequence uh
and you may identify variance within
that sequence and you'll be unsure
whether that variant is in fact a
sequencing
error uh a or it's a true variant and if
it's a true variant is it an important
one or a trivial one uh uh not having no
impact in yeah you will not know that
and but one of the other things of
course you can do is apply what we often
call an orthogonal method another
technology another methodology to the
same sample but focus it on that region
that you found the variant and ask the
question is the variant present using
another method and of course that other
method has different errors different um
you know different strengths and
different weaknesses and may allow you
to sort out whether you have a
sequencing error or in fact you have a
real variant it won't help you know
whether that variant is important or not
clinically uh but it will certainly help
you uh decide whether you have a
sequencing area or not so um the
application of orthogonal method whether
it be Sanger sequencing or genotyping or
even the application of another Next
gener Generation sequencing um method uh
following the initial Next Generation
sequencing method uh these these are all
uh have been suggested as ways to
confirm um um sequence variation and I
would say that it's extremely important
particularly if you're talking about a
high-risk uh patient or a patient where
you're about to engage in uh you know
important clinical activity that you do
rule out the fact that there are
potentially sequencing
problems
um all right uh and then I have two
other comments
uh uh from my colleagues that uh say
thank you for this and I appreciate
their comments and uh with that I think
we are at the end uh I'm I'll return uh
the uh Podium to our uh our conference
conveners uh with two minutes to spare
uh and I thank you all very
much